this film is Bethany and I play Aaron hi
I'm Zach ward on set immediately please
all right guys wardrobe is clear make
them familiar quiet freeze lock it up
Aaron is clears husband easy IT nerd a
bit of an Irish background and that's it
so we wrote it you both but James and
James and I wrote both the scripts so
actually since I last sign
no actually Corrections you did not
write in two months we did five days per
script well five on the first one seven
on the second so what we did you're
gonna you're gonna jump in anyways and I
want to I don't have to smack you on
camera so what happened was I had seen a
film that I was not impressed with and
it inspired me to do anything it was the
idea like don't let perfect be the enemy
of good so you called up James and like
I'm pulling the trigger on this I've got
a bunch of investors who put money into
other films before my thoughtful eyes
let's jam it out and get it done so
James had a distributor in front of his
we talked to him he said specifically
what he's looking for as opposed to
making up a movie they like this is my
passion project
it was here's the distributor watch so
it was haunted house film the ghost girl
and inside that niche we could do
whatever we wanted so we came up with
about twelve different concepts to him
he chose which ones he liked and then we
wrote them and we literally wrote them
over Christmas my girlfriend is very
very kind and understanding so over
Christmas we were locked in our offices
sleeping they're writing seventeen hours
a day jamming it out and we got we wrote
restoration in five days for the first
draft and then Bethany we wrote in seven
days and then we both went our separate
ways to do our polishes on each so I
would directed restoration he was going
to
bethenny so I polish restoration he post
bethenny so once we had that we already
had the distribution I talked to my
investors and at this budget we had a
good mg minimum guarantee so it wasn't
that much of a risk financially it was a
real thing to move forward with so we
did and it's you know it's micro budget
films it's hard it's really hard but we
have fantastic crews and wonderful
people that were working with and then
we have begged for every favor we can
get
so we then crewed up cast up locked it
down and started shooting
and we did them back-to-back so we did
we're doing six day weeks I restoration
was 14 shooting days six day weeks and
three days down and then started method
verse fourteen cheating days do you
write the script and to you every word
is bright and then you have the actors
read the script and sometimes you
realize that it doesn't work and you
just scratch it you just scratch it out
in neither James nor I get super upset
about anything especially if it just
sounds weird when someone says it we're
like man just cut that line there's
certain things that you you make sure to
work because they layer story and
they're important for the puzzle pieces
but if we write the word Oh baby I love
you I love you too baby we're like okay
cut out the baby thank you no thank you
no thank you
all right kind of to thank us and just
before me so when you were locked in the
office together what we listen to what
music he listens to classical music okay
I listen to Chopin and Beethoven and he
listens to movie scores so eventually at
first we were having him playing at the
same time and like it was like just
getting really annoying yeah so that we
both just started putting on headphones
and doing it and we were we were
actually living and got blowup
mattresses we lived in the office yeah
literally shut the doors through
Christmas
I gotta stayed there right again thanks
to my girlfriend for being just cool
understand period yeah she's awesome
awesome so that was that we did it and
it was funny because of the offices I'd
be in one room he'd be the other one and
we just email it back and forth with the
headphones in and come over me like hey
dude I emailed you that scene yeah okay
I got it
and then go back
well no at first we were right next to
each other and we were riding it and
doing that and then we just after being
locked in an office for like I don't
know one like 14 days or something that
was fine with brick walls yeah you just
don't want to it's the same office he
did his interview in yeah so after being
in that like cooped up place what and
the whole area so we had a whole area to
utilize so we we just haven't want to be
on the same yeah yeah yeah you make the
movie a bunch of different times you
come up with a concept and write it
that's your first time making the movie
then you shoot the movie then you edit
the movie when you score the movie so
you're merely making a movie for times
you know and throughout the process you
the thing that you thought was gonna be
awesome it was okay the other thing that
you didn't think was gonna be amazing
it was fantastic so you have these happy
accidents especially when you're doing
something with such a brief turnaround
and no prep time that you're finding
happy accidents actually at this point
we've got an amazing crew who's done not
only doing Bethany but it also did
restoration so the I think it's it's
moved itself out everybody's gotten
along figured out they like each other
they don't like each other you know
walked away from people that don't like
hung out with the people they do like
they're all professionals it's not like
someone has a major tantrum sits down
and pouts about it so the producing
aspect for me was far more
daily job in the beginning Rick getting
them raising the money closing
distribution deals getting all the
contract signs of that legal situations
ensuring that my investors are not
exposed to lawsuits making sure that
everybody's protected all those
mechanisms are in place legally before
you pull the trigger on something's that
you don't go to jail to lose your house
and blah blah but once we're here that
we also have a bunch of people who are
our associate producers and co producers
and production coordinators and it's
their job to handle it so I don't
micromanage because that would just be
stupid even though I we wrote both
scripts when it came to Bethany
James had done a rewrite polish tweaked
up things that he wanted to focus on and
then did an entire script breakdown
analyzing it from his own perspective
and he really raised the emotional
values and the scenes above what we had
originally written and delved into it
and gave it a different sense of meaning
so for Bethenny it's I'm letting him be
my director as opposed to me telling him
what I want to do I'm letting him say
okay this is the moment in this how this
reflects on the dynamic of the
relationship so play this be to suppose
that one okay whereas on restoration I
knew what I wanted to be done there were
my decisions so I'm directing myself to
not suck or directing my actors to find
that subtlety in the performance that is
based upon a different emotion than
what's written on the page so I let
James do his job and on restoration I
did my job
well you know when we wrote the script I
I like to I like people I like to watch
actors or playing roles people that I
wanted to hang out with
that way as perceiving a horror film
suspense work them then you care what
happens so there's a couple ways to do
that I think it's able to save the cat
moment where you see someone do
something generous are kind and
therefore you feel an affiliation with
them I also think that you that can be
done
I think also the same the cat moment can
be done no comment and the witty banter
back and forth between people the
interplay and then you feel like you
would want to hang out with them I think
Adam Sandler is proving that point in
his films and so I just try to translate
that into and it's not a comedy right
now this is a snack of meat and celery
carrots and hummus trusting yeah kind of
highfalutin for a micro budget film